[Music]
the smollett hoax is one of many that
fit a pattern angry Trumpkin unleash
vicious and hate-filled attacks against
sexual or racial minorities now here are
just a few of more than dozens that are
out there in December 2016 a Muslim
woman said she was attacked by three
white Trump supporters in New York City
on the subway she said they tried to rip
off her hijab well it never happened and
then one day after the 2016 election a
student at Bowling Green in Ohio said
that white males wearing Trump shirts
threw rocks at her and hurled racial
slurs protests in a university town hall
ensued the student made up the entire
incident and in September of last year a
woman told police on Long Island she was
driving home when fourteens confronted
her and yelled Trump 2016 and then they
told her quote she didn't belong here
that too was made up here now is Dinesh
D'Souza conservative filmmaker and
author Dinesh what does this tell us
about the current political climate and
the culture today well the first thing
it tells us is that these fake racial
incidents have become normalized
when the Tawana Brawley case broke a
generation ago this was a bogus racial
incident involving an african-american
woman who had claimed to have been
abused and battered it was anomalous
people really had to scratch their heads
because this was such a freak episode
but now there's a procession of these
bogus incidents of which the Jessie
smaller case is only the latest now I
think for people watching they're a
little baffled because they probably
think what kind of dementia causes
someone to do this why would somebody
fabricate an incident and I think that
we're dealing here not so much with
personal dementia but what can be called
ideological dementia you touched on it
earlier there's a narrative here that
they're trying to advance the narrative
is that the magus supporters the Trump
people are a bunch of racists now it's
obviously a tribute to the Trump stories
that they are not racist because the
jussie Smollett
despite
being black despite being flamboyantly
gay are going out there looking for
people to pick on them and nobody is so
the facts are not supporting the
narrative at all so they figure why not
make up the facts why not adapt the
facts to the narrative rather than the
other way around
and I think this is the demented
psychology the demented progressive
psychology that drives these racial
faked incidents and the second reason
for them is that they get away with it
well and this is what my point Dinesh is
that conservatives are quick to sort of
say oh let's move on what's I don't want
to dwell on this and in the fact that we
don't have people in jail after what
happened to Brett Kavanaugh with that
Julie sweat Nick what avenatti was
pushing all the promises of evidence of
how he he was drugging people spiking
the punch bowl gang rapes you know
people just want to move on from that I
say no way otherwise that stuff
continues it's same deal with this
Smollett case it ever II buddies time
and the Chicago PD was demonized and of
course Trump supporters are made out to
be these horrible awful terrible rotten
people because look your people are
doing this to this poor actor it's
important to realize that the jussie
Smollett incident is a hate crime it's a
hate crime but in the opposite direction
remember if Jesse Smollett basically
wanted to go and beat himself up that's
not against the law the real crime here
was attempting to pin this blame on a
bunch of people who did nothing on
innocent people and it is this idea of
trying to ultimately frame Trump
supporters for something that small at
himself perpetrated so he's the
perpetrator masquerading as the victim
it's very important that he had be held
accountable for that otherwise the left
basically thinks let's keep trying this
stuff when it works it works when it
doesn't we get away with it
Dinesh excellent analysis as always
thank you so much